jillian a wise man once said said then
we played bones and i'm yelling domino
that man was the incredible ice cube my
favorite and now you can yell domino as
the national tv pilot is going to be
filming right here in las vegas and it's
called domino time here to tell us more
is harold moray you a founder of the
universal domino league welcome thank
you thanks for having me this is very
exciting so this national television
pilot tell us a little bit more about
domino time well it is the
you could say the child of the universal
domino league we've hosted over i've
hosted over 100 domino tournaments over
the past decade almost decade
nationwide and it was finding the best
domino players from every city around
america and that's what we've done we
have over
75 champions that have championship
belts that have been crowned and we
wanted to bring a tv show
to las vegas because vegas is our home
and um you know give domino players a
platform to be recognized you know on on
a big scale
and um
you know
to uh really take this from a backyard
uh urban
so-called um
you know
hood game you'll say and make it sexy
and bring it to the forefront like poker
it's such a fun game but there's a lot
of strategy that's involved in this
there it there's a lot there's luck too
it's kind of like poker but with in a
way but with pieces of ivory
what do you what are you hoping that
this show it brings it to a national
level and makes it more mainstream right
that's what it is domino's is actually a
game of skill not chance yeah so it has
a little bit of randomness and chance to
it i'd say about 80 skill 20 chance
but you can get a bad hand and turn it
good or a good hand and turn it bad if
you don't know what you're doing
and or if you do know what you're doing
so
it's definitely strategy it's a game of
you know math uh and discipline and uh
knowing you know what you have in your
hand what's on the uh
table and really putting it together so
it's going to be some real interesting
people we encourage people come out
studio audience can come in free it's at
the luxor and watch
some of the best domino players in the
world compete for 10 000 and this will
be a
weekly show this is really cool now it's
at the hyperx esports arena over at the
looks or like you said eight of the best
domino players in the us they're gonna
compete for the chance to win ten
thousand dollars in cash have you
have you played in a lot of tournaments
i assume as well
you can't
yeah i don't think it'd be right you
know to host them and to create the
league and then i'm playing like i said
i don't i don't play dominoes i make
domino players famous oh i like that i
like that you know in a respectful
humble way but that's what you know my
mission was when i came to vegas went to
uh you know unlv was to learn how to
bring the game to the forefront in a way
that the you know world would love it to
be entertaining what's the best what's
the best piece to have in your mind
well to be the six the six six is always
great is that why you have it on your
neck yeah that's right i noticed that it
starts the game off the highest double
starts the game off and it's six six
five five four four three three one one
and zero zero so it's normally this
after this i would say a six three
because if you start with this and you
have or if your opponent starts with
this and you have six three score 15
points so it's the best of three matches
up to 150 points standard american style
dominoes but on a grand stage i mean you
could imagine it uh you know a thousand
people in a studio audience and you have
people rooting you on so it's different
than playing at your home backyard game
or on the table with a kitchen with your
family and friends getting in a fight
and throwing the dominoes everywhere
yeah this is gonna be and we have a
referee there it's real
you know big uh
monitoring 500 inch you know monitors
monster uh
monitors and um you know billion for the
facility at esports arena is second to
none it's going to be an amazing time
and you can be part of this they're
filming a live national tv pilot on
thursday july 28th at 6 p.m the hyperx
esports arena at the luxor hotel and
casino you can go to
universaldominoleague.com for more
information thank you so much harold
we'll be right back